hey guys it's Justine and today we're
unboxing the brand new PlayStation VR2 I
am so hyped about this I remember
unboxing the first PlayStation VR which
was like what like back in 2016 which
feels like in Tech time is pretty much
an eternity So today we're here with the
new PlayStation VR2 this is purely just
an unboxing so I'm not going to be able
to post my review until later I also
have a charging dock here which is
pretty cool this is the VR two sense
charging dock for the controllers one of
the biggest upgrades though is of course
with VR is obviously having a better
display so this is a 4K OLED display and
you'll have 110 degree field of view so
obviously as VR Tech progresses it's
going to be such a more comfortable
viewing experience for consumers you
might have to stand up oh no I've ripped
the ball I was gonna try to do this and
not rip it
oh okay
I didn't realize that the top just
folded open like that opened like that
so I just dumped everything anyway now
that we conveniently have everything out
of the box
here is the headset
I actually pick it up I mean it feels
pretty light considering like this cable
actually feels almost as heavy as the
headset which is kind of wild so we've
got this nice little headband here which
does have a very squishy
feel which is good for actually it's all
what's squishy all the way around that's
really nice because that's kind of where
it's going to be resting on your head
and that's the thing that makes it
really difficult when you spend a lot of
time inside of VR you want a headset
that's going to be very comfortable I
also like that these eyes are also
adjustable so you'll be able to adjust
the eye placement where you need your
eyeballs you can just use this little
scroll oh it's got this nice little
crank here on the back to make it
tighter or looser and you could just
press it to give you more space super
cool I hate putting this on with makeup
on but well we're doing it oh I love
that crank that's awesome it's kind of
like when you put on a helmet I know
some biking helmets have a little crank
on the back which allow you to kind of
just get a nice snug fit and so far
this actually feels really good it feels
like it has a very even distribution
around my head which is very nice I also
like that there's not a lot of pull
facing forward so because this is kind
of sitting a little bit lower right here
which is really cool that's giving it
kind of that equal distribution so it's
going to be awesome when I can actually
turn this on and plug it in but this is
purely the unboxing so I can't do that
yet this probably has makeup all over it
so another thing that I like is that
this kind of has this little space right
here so that's gonna give you some nice
airflow so I'm not going to feel super
suffocated and it also doesn't really
rest on your nose because I've
definitely tried some other headsets
before where it's a very uncomfortable
feeling because they're really relying
on your nose Bridge being kind of like
an anchor for the device and that is no
bueno in my book I mean it might be for
like the first five minutes and then
you're like oh there's a lot of pressure
not great so I do feel like this had
very nice equal distribution another
thing that's kind of cool about this is
it does have 3D audio so it's going to
give you a much more immersive
experience and it has eye tracking that
is something that until you really spend
time in VR like that's something that's
going to kind of give you that more
realistic experience because in real
life like you're not going to be moving
your head every single time you want to
look at something like you're just gonna
move your eyes and with that it's going
to feel way more natural and that's the
whole thing with VR is you want it to
feel real another thing that's really
great about the new psvr 2 is it really
only has this one connector where's the
other one before you had to have like
this separate little processor unit once
you used it like you got used to it but
now having way less Hardware like
everything is already built in you have
one single cable the original
PlayStation VR also relied heavily on
external cameras whereas this has pretty
much everything built in this has four
cameras plus that motor which is going
to be giving you that eye tracking
movement not only the eye tracking but
like having that eye tracking work
together with the head tracking it's
gonna be so cool let's check out the
controllers a shall we
they have adaptive triggers they have
haptic feedback they also have finger
touch detection and tracking rings so
this is going to really give you a much
more accurate representation of your
hands in space and that is something
that also is so disoriented when you're
in VR I feel like my hands aren't quite
matching up with what I'm doing so I
can't wait to actually see how this all
really plays out like is it gonna feel
normal is it going to feel more like my
hands are attached to my virtual body
and having that haptic feedback is way
more important than I think you would
think if you've never tried this before
because if you go to touch something in
real life like you'll actually feel a
sensation of that thing in your hand so
with this while you might not be able to
feel the item in your hand you kind of
virtually will be able to with that fake
haptic feedback touch so that's
definitely something that I think is
going to really make a big difference of
course it has the straps right here that
you can attach to your wrist so that you
don't drop them because that's all
something that is problematic is if you
drop one of your controllers like
where's it where did it go this has a
see-through view so you can actually see
what's going on around you without
having to take the headset off and
that's pretty nice I mean maybe
sometimes you should take the headset
off to have a little break if you will
but it is really nice that you don't
have to actually take the headset off to
be able to see so now let's check out
the PlayStation VR2 sense controller
charging station this is nice I can't
wait to get this all set up and get a
chance to really try it out
you just put these little inserts into
the controller and that allows you to
dock it how neat
power adapter
put in here I didn't open this from
before oh we've got the headphones and
another USBC cable these are very very
tiny little adapters check those out
Souls Mall
I'm so little
we go and then these just rest right
in there just like that that's cool
that's so nice let's take a look at the
headphones
but like I said these do give you that
3D audio which is going to be so fun
extra earbuds so here's everything that
comes in the Box I look forward to
actually getting a chance to power this
on and try it out but again this is just
the unboxing so you guys can see what it
looks like and I can tell you what it
feels like I'm definitely hyped to play
some games I'm really excited to play
the new Resident Evil game VR that's
going to be really fun I remember
playing like a Resident Evil game super
super early at E3 years and years ago
like this might have been even like my
first e3s that I'd ever been to and just
getting a chance to really play that
game and now actually play it many many
years later on this upgraded Hardware is
going to be I mean it's gonna be night
and day so I can't wait to test it out
thank you guys for watching if you
haven't already please subscribe and hit
the Bell to be notified when I post new
videos and leave me some comments below
and let me know what you guys think of a
PlayStation VR have you ordered one do
you want one what do you guys think of
VR in general I would love to hear it so
I'll see you guys there and in my next
video bye
[Music]